Could I start SEAC T? Thoughts on it? Is it good brand?
GenuineSEAC.com. I see you sell SEAC extract.
Is that a better or easier option?
Well, I'm not saying that our SEAC is better than another SEAC.
You know, I did scope out a lot of different SEAC products before I settled on the one that we use.
I do think that the ours is one of the better ones, though there may be other ones that are just as good.
So, but back to should I. So, could I start taking SEAC?
Yeah, you can. Should you? That's another question.
So we go back to the should I take everything that I hear about?
No, you should it. Could you? Yes, you could.
Could you overdo it and be taking too many things? Yes, you could.
So just keep that in mind again, like the last question.
Make sure that you you just pray about your decisions so that you aren't being influenced by anybody like your friend, you know,
emailing you saying you should really take this, this cured my friend or whatever.
You know, just keep that in mind.
So make sure you bane everything in prayer. Don't be influenced in the wrong way to be taking too many things because that can hurt your liver as well.